oh hi we're here at nintendo's media
summit in San Francisco where the
company is asking the question hey who
says that the we is just for people who
want to shake their controllers around
and play silly games and look like look
like idiots okay I guess it still is but
they've also got a lot of hardcore games
to show to dead rising chop to drop is
the ultimate zombie paradise shooting
madness the game features character
named Frank West who is trapped in a
gigantic mall somewhere in the American
Midwest and he's surrounded by literally
50,000 undead residents from the town
who are really not happy with so the
game has the player trying to not only
keep himself safe but also rescue
hostages were trapped in the mall and
have not yet become infected by the
zombies but but really it's about
wholesale destruction of undead enemies
so that the kind of the clever thing
about dead rising is that everything you
see in the mall is a weapon whether that
be a bench a garbage can even CDs in the
music store you can pick up and pearl
like throwing stars of course you have
weapons all around you have pistols and
shotguns yeah chainsaws because what's a
zombie game without chainsaws samurai
swords and even much otter weapons like
you can grab the giant parasols from the
food court actually use those as
battering rams running forward in
knocking zombies down
the wii remote will be used for all
sorts of different things in dead rising
so it'll be anything from swinging a bat
to knocking things down there's a you
can pick up a huge park bench actually
kind of use that as a battering ram
you'll also be able to use the Wii
Remote to aim with very precision shots
much like people found and resident evil
for the wii controller has ended up
being almost the perfect controller for
the kind of third-person shooting combat
that cap comes known for in our action
games this is the conduit a near future
kind of a sci-fi game in some sense and
that in the fact that Washington DC is
under attack by aliens that doesn't
happen till halfway through the game
there's a there's a whole conspiracy
thing that builds up until that point
but yeah for the most part you're you're
a secret agent working for a shadow
organization that's trying to trying to
unravel the conspiracy and in doing so
you find out that the alien invasion is
about to happen and thus does happen it
is a first-person shooter it's on the
week we're using a lot of we tuck that
you probably haven't seen before we have
a bright airy engine
as is doing some incredible stuff from
real-time water physics to all sorts of
graphical shaders we got detailed
mapping real-time lighting real-time
shadows so for the most part it's pretty
intense for what you would see on the we
that graphically it's pretty intense the
control scheme is is spot-on what you
would expect from a wee shooter it's
pretty much you got the reticle on the
screen and you point and you click you
got some grenade throwing we got some
unique we weapons in the game that
actually incorporates them some minor
twisting and stuff but for the most part
it's very intuitive to just pick up and
start playing all right called Roberto
war it takes place in the Pacific
Theater primarily you're going to be
fighting as US marine Raiders as you're
trying to take over the island the
Japanese islands like Peleliu okay now
you're going to spend some time on makin
and it also does have a European of
theater as well as the Russians push the
Germans back into Berlin so more
specifically with the wii hardcore gamer
is going to expect a lot of unique
features on a colony world at war so
there is going to be online competitive
multiplayer some of your traditional
game modes that you would expect are
going to return made engineered
specifically for the wii however was a
squad mate cooperative mode and that
means that i could I could come over and
pick up this we mote right now and hit
hit a and jump into the level that
you're in the middle of playing so we
don't just our from the beginning we
could play all the ways you can play all
the way through yourself and an innate
if at any point you need a friend and
ally to help you take out enemies like a
pick up a controller and they get a
second crosshair on the screen so it's
kind of an arcade style this is a very
fun game mode and we the wiimote
controls anything you could do on the
battlefield you can do with your remotes
you can like for example reloading you
can't hit the minus button we try to
keep those controls intuitively at your
fingertips
you